in duct suit Chico Marx asks who are you
going to believe me or your own eyes
when it comes to visual effects the
answer is not so simple
today is effects artists collaborate
with every other department to convince
audiences of even the most implausible
realities this is the kind of magic that
allows the audience to believe I was
actually obliterated by a truck in bird
box and the same kind of magic that
allows an audience to believe that I am
an actor here are this year's nominees
for achievement in visual effects
Avengers infinity war Dandeli Kelley
port Russell Earl and Dan student
Christopher Robin Christopher Lawrence
Michael Ames
Theo Jones and Chris Korbel first men
Paul Lambert Ian Hunter
Tristan miles and JD Shuang ready player
one
Roger Guyot Grady Coker mac
and division
solo a Star Wars story Robredo Patrick
Tuvok Neal Scanlan and Dominic two
and the Oscar goes to first man hunter
mr. miles
and JD swamp
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Tristan miles in JD Shuang the
second win and second time nominees Paul
Lambert and Ian hunter
[Music]
oh my goodness
oh what a truly magnificent moment we
did things a little bit differently on
first man's have been recognized by the
Academy is all the more special thanks
goes to my visual effects producer Kevin
Elam also Jennifer Bell and built to
last at Universal thank you to the
inspirational Damien Chazelle and and
our amazing cast cast and all the
incredible heads of department leanest
Tom Justin Mildred
a ling Nathan Rose Ian Josh Marion
Donald who made this film so so
memorable and a big shout out to
Michelle eyes and rank River Porter and
all my people at Dean egg Frank Hoover
thank you thank you again Damien
Chazelle my amazing effects team my wife
Erica I love you my two boys John and
James and my dad Jim who taught me how
to put the magic in movies thank you
thanks to the crew at Dean Inc without
whose hard work we wouldn't be stood up
here tonight also thanks to my wife
Kirsty and our two children Isabella
Eloisa for always support everything is
and it's a it's an honor it's humbling
to honor Neil Armstrong and all the men
and women of NASA so thank you so much
Kirsten perficio